and I think it's gone on for a while I
think there's a reason that dads would
protect their daughters from certain
guys and say stay away from my daughter
and obedient daughters right that that
were more Fe like because feminine women
are obedient so obedient daughters would
listen to their father and the
disobedient daughters would end up in a
single motherhood for a shotgun wedding
um and that's what the red pill talks
about they really just look at patterns
of behavior with women and thing is a
lot of women don't have genuine desire
for their husbands their husband was the
safe fall back guy and a lot of times
women treat him as such even if that is
true why is this woman publicly saying
that why why are you embarrassing your
guy and the problem is one none of the
men check the women so they don't even
tell the women how out of line that is